darks in the wind the longer he's there
the harder he's gonna be to catch you
know that whatever your please I got
your back remember what I promised you a
new beginning and you will have it once
we've brought this world to its end
Felicity's out of surgery didn't say
what was wrong I'm gonna kill him
hey youtubers is charlie so this is
going to be my arrow video we're just
breaking down the latest trailer just
confirming a couple things that we
already knew okay so the biggest thing
about this trailer is that they say that
felicity is coming out of surgery they
just kind of confirms that she's not
going to die I know a lot of you guys
have been asking me is she going to turn
into the Oracle character they actually
when they made the Felicity episode last
year what they did is the first title
they use for it was Oracle but Warner
Brothers was like nope you can't do that
we're going to be using the Barbara
Gordon Oracle character in something
else I think that's going to be the Teen
Titans show they just want to bookmark
her for that so they changed the name of
the Felicity episode to the secret
origin of Felicity Smoak that was goth
Felicity if you don't remember that
episode so I'm expecting a version of
what they did to all of her last season
where he was kind of at a commission for
a couple of episodes but not that
definitely not dead so the other big
part of the trailer is this attack
catalyzing team arrow coming together
Diggle no more is Diggle against Oliver
he's like whatever you're going to do
man whoever spine you gotta break I'm
totally behind you dude so the other big
thing is we see the anarchy symbol again
and I think this person here is like the
evolution of anarchy he's the anarchy
character that ran away in the comics he
wears a version of a mask like this this
is just a little truer to life like his
face is completely messed up remember
this other woman is the person that we
saw with Damian dark during the
mid-season finale with that child so
either it says wife or some sort of
partner but he talks about fulfilling a
promise so I'm wondering if he's bring
someone back from the dead raising some
crazy magic but whatever this pact is
that he's made he does seem like a
family man very evil family man and they
did say that one of the big themes of
arrow season four is what would you do
for your family so I'm guessing that
there's like a Damien dark side to that
equation too usually they're talking
about the arrow characters like all of
her family is team arrow what would he
do for them what crazy stuff so maybe
there's a damia dark version to that
story that's going to be told the second
half of the season the biggest thing you
really need to get excited for it's not
coming right away but it's coming in a
couple episodes Felicity's father's
coming on the show and it's going to be
the Roy episode I think I've already
talked about it in some of my previous
arrow videos he's the calculator and
he's going to be blackmailing Roy into
committing crimes for him so what might
end up happening is is Felicity will be
out of commission and they're just like
like Oliver came charging in during
season 3 like after he had full
healed he came swinging in on this big
zip cord Felicity will have her version
of that when she needs to take her
father down talk about daddy issues but
let me know what did you guys favorite
part of this trailer and it's slightly
related news there's a bunch of Batman V
Superman stuff that's happening so I'm
totally going to do a video for that
next because I'm on vacation that might
post a little bit later but you can just
follow me on Twitter and Facebook for
updates on when videos are coming
congratulations to this week's reverse
flash ring giveaway winner Alejandro
remotes please be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so and get your contact info what I'm
going to do is whenever I post my Batman
V Superman video I'll just really start
the giveaway so there will be a new
reverse flash ring giveaway this week y
cos wait for that to post you can click
here up at the top for my latest legends
of tomorrow trailer video it's going to
be so much fun and you can click down
here for the Deadpool red band trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you